بفضل الاجراءات السريعه التي اتخذتها
اداره خلال الايام الماضيه يجب على
الامريكيين ان يكونوا واثقين بان النظام
المصرفي امن والودائع موجوده عندما
تحتاجونها
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم القوات الروسيه تحاول
التقدم نحو وسط مدينه باكموت شرق اوكرانيا
من كل الاتجاهات والجيش الاوكراني يسرع من
وتيره التعزيزات العسكريه لقواته
المتمركزه وسط المدينه والكرملين يشدد على
ان اهداف روسيا في اوكرانيا لن تتحقق الا
بالسبل العسكريه
على خلفيه انهيار بنكي سيليكون فالي
الامريكي بايدن يقول ان تحرك ادارته
السريع لاحتواء الازمه يثبت للامريكيين ان
بامكانهم الثقه بالنظام المصرفي ويؤكد انه
لن يسمح بتحمل دافع الضرائب اي خسائر وانه
سيطلب من الكونجرس تجديد قوانين البنوك
مجلس النواب التونسي الجديد يعقد اولى
جلساته نقابه الصحفيين التونسيين تقول ان
منع سلطات الصحفيين من دخول البرلمان يفتح
الباب امام سياسات التعتيم وتكميم الافواه
وجبهه الخلاص المعارضه وحركه النهضه
تؤكدان عدم اعترافهما بالبرلمان الجديد
وتمسكهما بدستور 2014
مطالبين برفع اجورهم وتحسين ظروف عملهم
اطباء مبتدئون في بريطانيا يبداون اضرابا
عن العمل الغي على اثره عدد كبير من
العمليات ومواعيد المرضى اما في المانيا
فقد ادى اضرب موظفي الامن في ثلاثه مطارات
الى تعطل رحله اكثر من مئه الف مسافر
اليوم الى اللقاء